la séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion d'application de l'article 34
aligna 1 de la constitution de la
proposition de résolution appelant à la
dénonciation par les autorités
françaises de l'accord franco-algérien
du 27 décembre
1968 nous entamons la discussion
générale avec Madame Michelle Tabarot
pour les républicains et pour 10
minutes
bien madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
heureuse d'ouvrir cette niche
parlementaire au nom du groupe les
républicains aujourd'hui nous présentons
10 textes qui touchent à des priorités
absolues pour les Français l'immigra
l'éducation la petite enfance la santé
les transports publics la langue
française ou encore le logement nous
voulons défendre nos valeurs nos
convictions et surtout répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens de façon
claire efficace et
déterminé aussi j'espère que chacun sur
ses
bans avec chacun sur ses band nous
saurons nous retrouver sur ces
propositions et agir dans le sens de
l'intérêt général
mes chers collègues j'envens à notre
proposition de résolution qui ouvre
cette séance par ce texte nous invitons
le gouvernement à dénoncer l'accord
franco-algérien de 1968 sur
l'immigration cette initiative est très
importante parce que c'est le corelaire
indispensable du projet de loi de sur
l'immigration que nous allons examiner
la semaine prochaine en séance et je
veux dire ici que je regrette
sincèrement que plusieurs avancées
majeures adoptées par les sénateurs dont
je tiens à uer le travail pour durcir ce
texte est été modifié ou même supprimé
en commission des lois ce n'est pas en
reculant que l'on pourra reprendre le
contrôle de la situation
migratoire et ce n'est pas non plus en
rejetant nos propositions que l'on
parviendra à un
consensus nous avons besoin de réformes
ambitieuses et nous avons aussi besoin
de décisions courageuses pour les rendre
efficace parce que notre pays ne pourra
retrouver la maîtrise de l'immigration
qu'en faisant les choix qui s'imposent
face à des traités internationaux et
face à une jurisprudence européenne qui
nuis à notre
souveraineté c'est l'objectif de ces
deux textes sur l'immigration que nous
proposons aujourd'hui dans un instant
nous défendrons notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle monsieur soioti je
pense que vous la défendrez après moi
elle permettrait de proposer un
référendum sur l'immigration et de
déroger aux accords internationaux quand
notre souveraineté est en jeu c'est une
urgence si nous voulons mettre fin à
l'immigration de masse
incontrôlée c'est également l'objectif
de cette proposition de résolution vous
en connaissez les enjeux nous parlons
ici d'un traité international qui a une
autorité supérieure à la
loi de ce fait nous pourrons voter
autant de lois que nous souhaitons tant
que l'accord de 68 ne sera pas dénoncé
nous ne retrouverons jamais une capacité
totale à maîtriser les flux
migratoires
parce que cet accord nous en
empêche vous le savez il crée un régime
privilégié au bénéfice des
ressortissants algériens il instaure un
droit quasi automatique à l'immigration
il favorise leur entrée et leur
installation il prévoit un document
spécifique le certificat de résidence
pour les
Algériens il facilite aussi la venue des
conjoints pour le regroupement
familial il rise également des
régularisations de plein droit après 10
ans de présence illégale sur notre
territoire voilà la réalité de cet
accord qui n'a plus lieu d'être
aujourd'hui déjà parce qu'il a été
adopté il y a 55 ans le contexte n'est
évidemment plus le même depuis
l'instauration de ce régime
dérogatoire d'un point de vue économique
tout d'abord nous sommes aujourd'hui
très loin de l'expansion que nous avons
connu à la fin des années
60 le besoin de M n'est plus le même du
point de vue de la pression migratoire
ensite l'Algérie est le 2uxème pays
d'origine des primos bénéficiaires de
titre de séjour d'après l'INC en 2022
880000 étrangers en France étaient né en
Algérie 12,5 % des immigrés en France
viennent de ce pays d'après
Fondapol chaque année entre 2017 et 2020
10000 Algériens en situation irrégulière
sont restés en France
comment prétendre retrouver la maîtrise
quand la première diaspora de la France
échappe à nos lois et à notre droit
commun du
séjour nous devons réagir et nous devons
le faire avec force et
détermination monsieur le ministre nous
avons entendu les arguments du
gouvernement vous allez nous dire que la
dénonciation serait juridiquement
impossible ou dangereuse mais
l'immobilisme n'apporte rien de bon
quand il est motivé par la peur
l'excellente étude de Xavier dan courour
donne beaucoup de réponses à vos
questions d'abord sur la dénonciation
unilatérale la Convention de Vienne de
69 sur le droit des traités s'applique
rien n'empêche de dénoncer l'accord s'il
n'a pas vocation à être
perpétuelle et même si c'était le cas
qui pourrait nous en
empêcher ensuite monsieur le ministre
vous allez nous dire que la situation
pourrait être au final plus défavorable
qu'avant il faudrait alors nous
expliquer comment le fait de mettre fin
à un régime dérogatoire pour appliquer
nos lois pourrait être un
danger quant au prétendu risque d'un
retour à la libre circulation si
l'accord était dénoncé une note de la
direction juridique du qu d'orsé affirme
que l'accord de 68 a implicitement
abrogé les funestes d'accord des viiant
sur ce point
ensuite nous sommes souverains si plus
aucun traité ne s'impose alors nous
pourront décider des conditions d'entrée
sur notre
territoire enfin les règles de l'espace
Schengen s'appliquent à nos frontières
si cet accord était dénoncé nos
autorités soumettraient sans nul doute
les ressortissants algériens à
l'obligation de présenter un visa avant
l'entrée sur notre territoire au-delà de
ces questions juridiques il y a un
certain nombre d'arguments politiques
avancés par le gouvernement c'est sans
doute là que se trouve notre véritable
point d'achopement d'ailleurs il
semblerait que le président de la
République vive assez mal notre
initiative et voudrait dénier au
Parlement le droit de traiter des
affaires étrangères mais nous en sommes
pleinement légitimes à en parler au lieu
de s'enfusquer le chef de l'État serait
bien inspiré de sortir de son exercice
solitaire de la diplomatie et de nous
écouter un peu plus souvent je rappelle
que je rappelle que quand la majorité
présente des résolutions sur la
politique étrangère nous en débattons et
nous les votons sans que cela ne pose
problème au président de la République
alors monsieur le ministre vous allez
nous dire que nous risquons de mettre à
mal le prétendu réchauffement de nos
relations avec l'Algérie mais de quoi
parlons-nous le président tbou n'a
aucune volonté de dialoguer avec la
France faut-il rappeler toutes ses
provocations faut-il rappeler qu'il a
préféré aller voir Vladimir Poutine qui
l' qualifié d'ami de l'humanité plutôt
que de venir en France fautil il
rappeler qu'il a réintroduit dans l'hyne
algérien un couplé violemment
antifrançais de façon totalement
honteuse faut-il aussi rappeler la
suspension faut-il faut-il rappeler la
suspension seul seule l'uratrice à la
parole s'il vous plaît faut faut-ilpp
prendrez la parole tout à l'heure seule
s'il vous plaît seule l'oratrice à la
parole et elle seule faut-il rappeler la
suspension des laisser passer
consulaires et son refus de reprendre
ses ressortissants que nous voulons
expulsé la réalité c'est qu'il y a
toujours des tensions très vives et très
peu de volonté du pouvoir algérien de
les apaiser même si le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous fa voudrait faire
croire le
contraire dans ce contexte l'accord de
68 et son régime privilégié n'ont
évidemment plus de raison d'être
monsieur le ministre notre démarche est
légitime elle est indispensable vous le
savez et c'est bien pour cela que
l'exécutif propose désormais une
révision de cette acccord alors même que
nous venons de déposer cette proposition
de résolution mais là aussi soyons clair
un simple avenant ne serait qu'une
demi-mesure tant que cet accord existera
il y aura un régime dérogatoire qui
échappera à la loi il a déjà été
revisité trois fois sans que jamais les
principes qui le fondent ne soient remis
en cause voilà pourquoi le groupe les
républicains veut aller plus loin et
voilà pourquoi nous souhaitons purement
et simplement dénoncer cet
accord je vais regarder mes chers
collègues l'heure n'est pas au calcul
politicien et aux
arrière-pensées nous pardon pardon
pardon atten attention à ce que vous
dites attention à ce que vous dites
alors vous dites ce que vous
voulezsieur Présidente je pense qu'il a
une
présidente mes chers
collègues alors alors si vous souhaitez
faire un rappel au règlement vous le
faites vous laissez madame l'oratrice
terminer son intervention et vous
pourrez le faire après mes chers
collègues l'heure n'est plus au calcul
politicien et aux
arrière-pensé nous savons que notre
constat est largement partagé par
plusieurs groupes sur ces bancs
aujourd'hui nous pouvons envoyer un
message fort pour montrer notre
détermination commune alors je vous
invite à être fidèle à vos convictions
et à voter cette proposition de
résolution avec responsabilité avec
pragmatisme et avec courage c'est ce que
les Français réclam et c'est ce qu'ils
attendent de nous aujourd'hui alors
soyons au rendez-vous merci merci madame
la députée alors je vais
juste faire une lecture de l'alinéa 3 de
l'article 70 pour rappeler que il ne les
députés n'ont pas se livré à une mise en
cause personnelle interpell un autre
député ou adressé à un ou plusieurs de
leurs collègues des injures provocation
ou menaces j'espère que ça pourra être
appliqué toute cette journée monsieur
balanan rappel au
règlementusez-moi j'avais j'avais mis
mon j'avais sorti le règlement et c'est
sur les mêmes
fondements j'ai entendu des propos
voilà mais surt j'aiend après quelque
chose qui est de je dis ce que je veux
ici
oui on a une immunité parlementaire mais
elle nous engage aussi une
responsabilité elle nous engage à la
responsabilité d'être courtois mais ça
vous avez oublié depuis très longtemps
de le faire de respecter nos
institutions et de respecter notre règle
de nos règles de droit donc franchement
franchement essayons d'avoir des débat
vous savez nous notre groupe s'opposera
notre groupe s'opposera à à cette
résolution mais ça nous empêche
n che de triller sinement et d'arrêter
les invectives permanentes
merci alors je vais passer la parole au
monsieur de l'uguste s'il vous plaît au
deè orateur Monsieur Frédéric petit pour
le groupe démocrate et pour 5
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues au départ de mon intervention
je voudrais que nous prenions une vision
d'ensemble sur l'état actuel de notre
relation avec
l'Algérie vous avez dit
Madame madame la précédente oratrice
vous avez dit que nous faisions croire
qu'il n'y av pas de tension je rappelle
que la commission des affaires
étrangères dans un rapport sur le budget
et après une mission que j'ai effectué
en Algérie a appelé à la révision de cet
accord dans un texte qui est accessible
depuis 4 mois l'état actuel de notre
relation avec l'Algérie se caractérise
par des faits sur lesquels je pense nous
Serom tous nous serons tous d'accord dé
blocages de diplomatie institutionnelle
vous l'avez rappelé je vais même plus
fort ce que j'ai vu sur le terrain c'est
du harcèlement francophobe administratif
et parfois peu compréhensible parce
qu'il est y compris dans sa propre
logique parfois absurde c'est un tempo
qui est dicté uniquement par les agendas
intérieurs alors que nous parlons de
diplomatie puisque nous parlons d'accord
international mais il ne faut pas
oublier ma cher collègue que en Algérie
il y a une énorme présence de français
de
francophiles de liens entre sociétés
civil de liens culturel une francophonie
très présente ce que j'avais appelé dans
mon rapport très souvent sous les radars
et puis effectivement il y a aussi une
très grosse présence d'Algérien en
France et de Français d'origine
algérienne vous avez rappelé les
chiffres dont une immense majorité est
intégrée et créatrice de richesse je
vous rappelle un chiffre que vous avez
oublié de citer du même rapport c'est
que les Algériens sont la plus grosse
nationalité à être à être bénéficiaire
du contrat d'intégration républicaine
mes chers collègues je voudrais rappeler
par cette petite introduction de
commissaire des Affaires étrangères on
ne peut pas traiter les questions de
migration internationale les yeux rivés
sur notre territoire ou pire les yeux
rivés sur notre microcosme je pense
qu'il est important de poser les enjeux
entre nos deux pays de manière globale
avant de prendre des décisions
hatives effectivement nos relations avec
l'Algérie sont illisibles chaotiques
certains les voient comme un rapport de
force souvent fantasmé d'autres comme un
rêve illusoire de coupure ou un lent et
inéluctable divorce
ou des annonces toujours recommencé de
grands retours de flamme pour un statut
quo éternel c'est un un are sens
l'origine peut-être compréhensible de
cette proposition de résolution qui est
maladroite sinon démagogique et qui
traite mal une vraie question je
rappelle qu'on ne soigne pas la
varicelle en traitant les boutons trois
faits cette proposition de résolution
nous mettrait hors du droit
international au-delà de notre relation
avec l'Algérie notre pays ne peut pas
aller dans cette direction de façon
diplomatique le droit international est
remis en cause aujourd'hui notre pays
doit maintenir le droit international ne
peut pas s'en s'en s'en échapper
deuxièmement elle est beaucoup trop
réductrice vous avez utilisé madame
chers collègu le mot empêche non nous
avons réduit dans le droit actuel nous
avons réduit nos visas de 400 de plus de
410000 à à un peu plus de 100000 pour
faire pression sur les retours l'action
n'est pas l'action de la France n'est
pas bridée et enfin vous l'avez dit
également ça serait évidemment
contreproductif non seulement il y
aurait un risque de revenir à 62 mais
vous avez cité vous-même Schengen
Schengen est dans bien des domaines plus
avantageux que la situation de
68 ce n'est pas de la peur dont nous
parlons ce traité effectivement ne
correspond plus au contexte de 55 ans y
compris au détriment de notre partenaire
algérien il faut donc le renégocier
c'est ce que j'ai dit il y a 4 mois
c'est ce que nous pensons dans notre
groupe il faut le renégocier c'est cela
la route diplomatique respectueuse du
droit international et qui permettra
efficacement de sortir de l' brliot que
pouvons-nous et que devons-nous exiger
et bien par exemple ce que personne ne
cite ici mais qui me concerne et qui est
tout à fait en logique avec la position
globale que j'ai apporté la francophonie
nous devons renégocier en disant vous
demandez des facilités et vous casser
l'apprentissage du français dans votre
pays ce n'est pas normal ça nous pouvons
le faire si faisons une action
diplomatique et pas une action dans
notre coin nous pouvons évidemment
demander la révision du droit des
travailleurs qui est effectivement pas
adapté aujourd'hui ou de la du
regroupement familial qui n'est pas de
droit commun que pourrions-nous apporter
aux Algériens c'est rendre applicable
aux Algériens aux étudiants le passeport
talent le passeport frenchtech le séjour
pluré à Muel des étudiants les étudiants
algériens chez nous sont évidemment
désavantagés par rapport aux
autres le groupe démocrate n s ce texte
parfois il faut être intelligent pour
deux au lieu de s'isoler
[Applaudissements]
bêtement merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame fa ki pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes seul madame la parole s'il vous
plaît merci madame la
Présidente mes chers
collègues souvenez-vous souvenez-vous de
la première séance pliniiaère dans notre
hémicycle en 2022 une journée ternie
ternie par le discours honteux d'un
député d'extrême droite un discours
blessant ventant les mér les mérites de
l'Algérie française ventant la
colonisation
aujourd'hui c'est autour de la droite de
nous servir cette vieille soupe Rance et
stigmatisante envers les Algériens et
envers l'histoire singulière de la
France avec l'Algérie nourri d'un
imaginaire postcolonial teinté de la
nostalgie d'un temps révolu révolu tras
d'union entre la droite et l'extrême
droite dans cet hémicycle au lieu de se
préoccuper du quotidien des Français de
l'inflation galopante le groupe LR
propose aujourd'hui de attaquer à un
accord international l'accord
franco-algérien de 68 alors même que
notre hémicycle n'a pas le pouvoir de le
remettre en cause tout d'abord cet
accord est évidemment indissociable de
l'histoire singulaire qui niit notre
pays avec l'Algérie une histoire
complexe dont bon nombre de nos
concitoyens sont les héritiers c'est le
témoignage d'une histoire partagée
longue de 132 ans de colonie
dont 8 ans de guerre d'indépendance et
six décennies 6 décennies de relations
bilatérales
sinueuse une relation tumultueuse et
donc une relation fragile parfois
inflammable et à laquelle vous voulez
aujourd'hui mettre le
feu cet accord signé en 68 et renégocié
déjà trois fois de suite était
d'ailleurs initialement une volonté de
la France de revenir sur les accords
d'viant et donc de revenir sur la libre
circulation qu'il
permettait rentrons donc dans le dur du
texte vous énumérez dans votre PPR les
dispositions les plus favorables au
séjours des algériens en France notons
que le principal point favorable de ce
traité est qu'un Algérien installé en
France depuis plus de 3 ans peut
bénéficier d'une carte de résidence pour
10 ans contre 5 ans pour le droit commun
oh nous avons vu bien plus exorbitant
comme
avantage mais vous omettez bien sûr
siamment chers collègues d'énumérer
parmi les dispositions celles qui sont
les plus défavoraable aux
Algériens et qui sont bien plus strictes
que le droit commun de tous les
étrangers en France par exemple pour les
étudiants ce sont les seuls les
étudiants algériens qui sont soumis à
une autorisation préalable provisoire de
travail et comme si cela ne suffisait
pas ils ne peuvent travailler que 50 %
de la durée légale et enfin vous
prétendez que cet accord est un appel
d'air vers une immigration contrôlée
incontrôlée et incontrôlable des
Algériens pourtant la France a fait
largement très largement la
démonstration qu'elle avait la main sur
l'immigration légale algérienne qui est
d'ailleurs stable par une politique de
visa très stricte rappelons enfin que
l'immigration illégale comme
l'éloignement comme les contrôles et les
sanctions ou encore le droit d'asile des
Algériens ne sont pas du tout régis par
cet accord et relèvent du droit commun
je vous le dis clairement non il
n'existe pas ni droit inconditionnel ni
droit automatique à l'immigration des
algériens en
France répondons enfin à la question que
tout le monde se pose que se
passerait-il si cet accord était dénoncé
unilatéralement par notre
assemblée si une telle dénonciation
aboutissait imaginons-le une seconde
elle conduirait à en toute probabilité à
un statut qu NT c'est-à-dire au retour
des dispositions des accords déviant et
donc à une libre circulation des
algériens en France je doute très
sérieusement que ce soit l'intention
initiale des auteurs de ce
texte mes chers collègues ne vous
rendez-vous pas compte que même si ce
que ce qui produit aucun effet juridique
peut avoir des conséquences sociales et
des conséquences diplomatiques
désastreuse au-delà de son caractère
stigmatisant envers les Algériens
première communauté étrangère établie en
France ce texte est une Hae à la
brutalité des relations
internationales cette proposition est
donc irresponsable et fait courir un
risques grave dans les relations
bilatérales déjà fragiles qui peut
croire aujourd'hui qu'une telle manœuvre
contribue de quelconque manière au
renouvellement de la relation entre la
France et l'Algérie si ce n'est que de
l'envenimer davantage votre proposition
est un leure nous dénonçons
l'instrumentalisation et vous bien sûr
la haine des étrangers systématiques
avec l'Algérien comme
épouvantaille la parole est à Madame
Stéphanie cocher pour le groupe horizon
et apparenté pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la
présidence monsieur le ministre mes
chers
collègues plus de 60 ans après
l'indépendance il est temps de
normaliser les relations entre la France
et l'Algérie cela s'impose comme une
émidence alors même que nous réformons
nos procédures en matière d'asile et
d'immigration au niveau national et au
niveau européen on devrait pouvoir
s'attendre à ce que ces évolutions
s'appliquent à tous que notre politique
d'accueil traite de de manière
équilibrée chaque ressortissant selon sa
situation personnelle certes des accords
bilatéraux existent pour faciliter la
circulation le séjour et l'emploi des
ressortissants de certains pays mais
aucun d'entre eux ne sort autant du
droit commun que l'accord
franco-algérien du 27 décembre
1968 à en écouter les partisans de cet
accord il serait légitime car issu d'une
histoire de 132 années de colonisation à
la mémoire douloureuse mais aussi
justifié par les facilités de
circulation existantes avant
l'indépendance mais la mémoire ne doit
pas s'imposer comme l'alpha et l'oméga
de nos politiques
publiques de même 60 ans après notre
relation avec l'Algérie doit pouvoir se
construire sur des bases saines la
création d'une commission mixte
d'historien sur l'histoire de la
colonisation portée par le Président de
la République permettra notamment de
dépolitiser et d'apporter sereinement le
passé en parallèle la visite de la
première ministre le 9 octobre 2022 à
Alger a permis de renouveler les
partenariats pour l'économie la mobilité
et la jeunesse ces partenariats
renouvelés prouvent que l'on peut
s'émanciper de la mémoire
franco-algérienne dans de nombreux
domaine cela devrait être aussi le cas
pour la politique
migratoire le groupe horizon et
apparenté soutient la remise en cause de
l'accord
franco-algérien nous considérons que cet
accord relève d'une exception
exceptionnal car relevant d'une histoire
et d'une mémoire que la France comme
l'Algérie cherchent à dépasser
exceptionnel aussi de par les facilités
démesurées qu'il accordde à une partie
de la population immigrée en
France au regard des des 16 accords qui
lient la France à des pays avec lesquels
nous partageons une histoire notamment
coloniale les stipulations de l'accord
sont beaucoup plus favorable que le
droit commun pour les ressortissants
algériens seuls les citoyens algériens
peuvent bénéfici d'une régularisation
simplement justifiant d'une résidence en
France même illégale depuis plus de 10
ans en cas de regroupement familiale
l'exigence d'une intégration et
d'insertion réussie dans la société
française n'est pas vérifiée le conjoint
algérien peut aussi obtenir un
certificat de de résidence de 10 ans
après un an de mariage seulement contre
3 3 ans de vie commune pour les autres
nationalités de par son caractère
exceptionnel cet accord ne peut perdurer
indéfiniment dans une situation qui
satisfait ni la France ni l'Algérie la
France demande en retour depuis de
nombreuses années une coopération
renforcée dans la reconduite à la
frontière des clandestins et le nombre
de laissés passer consulaires accordé
par l'Algérie de leur côté certains
étudiants et professionnels Algériens se
voient de par cette situation
particulière exclus de dispositifs
réservés aux étrangers en France comme
le passeport talent et les carts de
séjour recherche d'emploi création
d'entreprise ou stagiaire salarié
dénoncer cet accord pose des questions
délicates en termes juridiques plus
encore en termees diplomatiques nous ne
minimisons pas les difficultés que cela
engendrerait il revient évidemment à
l'exécutif de fixer les objectifs de
notre politique étrangère sur ce
sujet c'est parce que nous sommes
convaincus qu'il appartient Infiné au
président de la République de fixer les
objectifs de la nation à l'international
que nous n'aurions pu dépouser nous-même
un tel texte mais puisqu'il nous a dem
aujourd'ui de nous prononcer sur la
question nous voterons en faveur de
cette proposition de
résolution merci Madame
laputé la parole est à Madame Sabrina
pour le groupe écologiste pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
en 1961 Jean-Paul Sartre définissait
Franz Fanon militant et activiste de la
lutte pour l'indépendance du peuple
algérien comme la personne la plus
séduisante et bouleversante qu'il
n'avait jamais rencontré en 1962
Jean-Marie Le Pen livré dans une
entrevue nous avons torturé en Algérie
parce qu'il fallait le faire depuis les
nostalgiques de l'Algérie française
n'ont cessé de conter leur vérité leur
vision eucumunique de l'histoire
pourtant contesté par l'ensemble des
historiens chercheurs et sociologues
Gérard Longuet Ministre de votre
majorité madame la rapporteur faisait un
bras d'honneur à l'Algérie en 2012 José
gonzalz un peu plus à droite de vos ban
ouvrait notre législature en invoquant
sa nostalgie de l'Algérie française
vous-même madame vous nous avez gratifié
d'un certain refus de repentance
mémorielle et d'accord d'indépendance
que et je vous cite trouver funeste je
passerai bien évidemment vos amis tels
que jean-px mfry j'entend j'entend
joyeusement nostalgéie dans la ville que
vous avez administré depuis plus de 20
ans et cette résolution mes chers
collègues elle est la continuité
malheureusement logique de cette
idéologie Rance nostalgique du temps
béni des colonies sur fond
d'islamophobie de racisme antialgérien
132 ans c'est le nombre d'années que la
France a passé comme puissance occupante
du territoire algérien alors même que
des Algériens mais aussi des Français
sont encore les témoins vivants des
massacres perpétrés par l'armée
française lors de la guerre
d'indépendance vous nous expliquez que
l'accord de 1968 est instrumentalisé
comme une forme de du en compensation
des années de colonisation mais enfin
avez-vous du respect madame la
rapporteur avez-vous du respect pour les
étudiants algériens qui ne peuvent pas
disposer de titrre pluriannuel ou
travailler directement comme tous les
autres étrangers sur notre sol sans
autorisation de la préfecture c'est cela
pour vous un régime favorable avez-vous
du respect pour nos traités
internationaux cela même qui tortent le
coup à votre résolution ou alors à moins
que vous soyez désormais de ceux qui
appellent à la désobéissance un peu
comme les soulèvements de la terre
dénoncer unilatéralement ce traité selon
de nombreux juristes c'est revenir aux
accords des Viant cela même qui prévoyit
une liberté de circulation totale entre
l'Algérie et la France je ne suis pas
certaine que votre ligne tique soit une
ouverture plus large aux portes de notre
pays quand vous préférez laisser les
migrants en Méditerrané quand le patron
de votre formation politique déclare
qu'aucun port ne doit accueillir des
navires humanitaires et quand vous
demandez que des mineurs soient enfermés
en centre de rétention
administrative alors votre
résolution ce n'est que de l'affichage
politicien vous voulez faire plaisir à
la frange de votre électorat la plus
extrême celle là même que vous retenez
le plus possible afin que que sa voix ne
parte pas au rassemblement national vous
versez dans les clichés tous plus
honteux les uns que les autres et tant
pis pour l'histoire et la vérité tant
pis pour cet accord qui a été conclu
dans un contexte de sortie de
colonisation tant pis pour l'histoire
tant pis pour les Algériens tant pis
pour ces Français d'origine algérienne
qui sont aujourd'hui médecins ingénieurs
élu ici sur ces bancs maire sénateur
ministres vous préférez toujours du
doigt quelques cas isolés pour en faire
des généralités ou transanières et ainsi
agiter le chiffon rouge entre deux
peuples qui pourtant ont beaucoup plus à
souffrir qu'à s'arracher finalement
cette résolution est dans la droite
ligne des Herms de politique étrangère
de notre pays on sacrifie l'intérêt du
pays pour des considérations de bas
populisme la vérité consiste à dire que
des siècles d'histoire nous unissent que
dans la vraie vie et pas sur X des liens
de profonde amitié unissent les peuples
algériens et français cette Mo
ne fera qu'affaiblir la position de la
France en Afrique et au Maghreb ayons le
courage de dire que cette résolution est
une erreur et qu'elle tourne le dos même
aux engagements du Président de la
République lors de sa visite en Algérie
ainsi nous ne voterons pas cette
résolution parce qu'elle tort le coup à
des siècles d'histoire à des milliers
d'historiens de scientifiques de
spécialistes mais avant tout à
l'humanité nous ne voterons pas cette
résolution parce que nous devons
continuer le travail de mémoire sur
cette page sombre de notre histoire et
non la rayer voire pire la glorifier
nous ne sommes pas de ce construisons
des murs mais des ponts vous l'aurez
compris nous ne sommes pas de ce
sombrons aux pires sirènes démagogique
obsédé par l'Algérie et les Arabes nous
ne voterons pas cette résolution car
c'est une manière de tourner le doigt à
la Méditerranée et à notre histoire
j'espère ici que chacun saura que sa
voix compte je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la parole est à Madame
souia broua pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine duup et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues à la lecture de
cette proposition de résolution nous
comprenons vite et bien que nous
n'aurons pas aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle des débats constructifs sur
les liens qui unissent entre nos pays et
l'Algérie en effet le fond de cette
résolution se limite à un objectif
étriqué et bouger je vous cite arrêterz
l'immigration de masse c'est donc à cela
que vous résumez la relation étroite et
complexe qui liit le peuple français au
peuple algérien nous aurions pu parler
de partenariat culturel d'échang
universitaire et scientifique ou de la
nécessité d'un travail mémoriel commun
autour de l'histoire de nos deux pays
qui ne se résume pas au flux migratoires
auquel vous voulez réduire dans le
climat médiatique nosabons que nous
connaissons actuellement où les discours
idéologiques de l'extrême droite
s'expriment librement les membres du
groupe les républicains ont fait le
choix malheureux d'en reprendre les
thèmes et les
termes la France et l'Algérie partage
une histoire commune longue de plus d'un
siècle pendant 130 années les Algériens
et les Français ont partager une même
nationalité c'est l'histoire a été
profondément marquée par la violence de
la colonisation à travers des
expropriations de Laon de privation de
liberté et une négation profonde de la
dignité humaine par domination politique
économique et culturelle qui a
profondément blessé humilié et fait
beaucoup de
victimes cette histoire nous devons la
reconnaître nous devons l'assumer tant à
travers les fait que par les mots pour
la qualifier oui la colonisation est un
crime contre l'humanité et la
décolonisation qui s'en est suivie de
l'Algérie ne fut pas moins terrible au
regard de ces années de colonisation où
les Français d'Algérie circulaient
librement sur l'ensemble du territoire
français parce que les besoins en main
d'œuvre d'une économie en pleine
expansion était importante il n'est pas
surprenant que les ressortissants
algériens représentent aujourd'hui la
première nationalité étrangère cela fait
maintenant plus de 60 ans que la a pris
fin et que l'Algérie a obtenu son
indépendance pour autant ces blessires
ne cycatriseront pas sans un véritable
travail mémoriel en ce sens l'ouverture
des archives est un combat utile et
nécessaire pour comprendre notre
histoire et œuvrer pour l'avenir de nos
deux pays je déplore que cette
résolution ne s'emploie pas à la
restauration de relations diplomatiques
sereines et respectueuses entre
l'Algérie et la France de plus ce texte
s'inscrit dans des débats sur la loi
immigration thématique devenue seu
boussole d'une droite à perte de
repère l'accord franco-algérien de 68
établit des conditions dérogatoires au
droits commun relatifs à la circulation
à l'emploi et au séjour en France des
ressortissants algériens cet accord
n'est pas injustifié il a eu une raison
d'être qui étaé historique et en ce sens
ce ne sont pas des privilèges et encore
moins une anomalie ce sont les
conséquences d'une histoire commune qui
demeure je m'étonne d'ailleurs de la
sélection des conditions dérogatoires
que vous qualifiez d'avantageuse car à
côté des exemples que vous avez cités
les ressortissants algériens n'ont pas
accès à plusieurs titres de séjours tels
que les passeports talents les cartes
pluriannuelles le titre de séjour pour
motifs humanitaires qui sont comme les
victimes de la traite ou la violence
conjugale et n parlons pas des
difficultés administratives
pour les étudiants algériens qui
souhaitent venir étudier en France par
ailleurs la France a drastiquement
baissé le nombre de visas qu'elle
délivrait au ressortissant Algériens en
2017 il y avait
412000 visas qui ont été délivré en 2022
seulement 131000 ont été
accordés enfin c'est s compter les
difficultés qu'ont de nombreux Algériens
qui sont nés en France sur le territoire
algérien ou en France hexagonale qui ont
perdu la nationalité française après
l'indépendance de l'Algérie et pour ces
femmes et ses hommes obtenir la
réintégration dans leur nationalité
d'origine relève du parcours du
combattant et ce qui est une véritable
injustice aussi face à votre vision
réductrice des relations entre nos deux
pays nous ce que nous voulons c'est
rebâtir un partenariat qui soit resserré
et empreint de respect et de respect ça
soit équilibré sur ce qui rassemble nos
deux peuples eux qui ont tant en commun
vous l'avez certainement deviné après
mon exposé que mon groupe le groupe GDR
ne votera pas ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane leenorman pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outreem et
territoire et pour 5 minutes rappel au
règlement Monsieur Le Coq sur le
fondement de quel article 70 merci
madame la Présidente en vertu de
l'article 70
on a entendu pendant la l'intervention
de de ma camarade et de la députée
Soum vous parlez au nom de qui je voudis
rappeler au nom de mon groupe que quand
une députée du groupe GDR parle à
l'Assemblée nationale elle parle au nom
du peuple français comme l'ensemble des
députés et et seulement au nom du peuple
français donc je souhaitais que ce soit
noté cette intervention et et je pense
que ce genre d'interprélation n'a pas sa
place ici merci monsieur le député
monsieur LEM vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues les auteurs de
cette proposition de résolution estime
que l'accord franco-algérien de 1968 est
désué problématique et injuste les
réticence de l'Algérie s'agissant des
otf ainsi que les nombreux refus de
titre de séjour de longue durée pose en
effet la question de la
réciprocité la refonte de nos relations
ne peut-être basée sur la Sy et
l'inégalité nous devons par ailleurs
être vigilant étant donné que cet accord
rejaillisse sur l'espace Schengen cela
étant dit en matière deoctf et le
rapport de la fondaple que vous citez
dans l'exposé des motifs précise que les
performances de l'Algérie dans ce
domaine sont meilleur que celles des
autres pays du Maghreb dès lors nous ne
partageons pas votre volonté de faire de
cet accord un totem de la politique de
l'immigration ou un sujet incontournable
de la diplomatie française au Maghreb
premièrement la présence des
ressortissant algérien est à relativiser
selon l'INC elle est resté quasiment
stable sur les 5 dernières années entre
600 et 610000 détenteurs de titres de
séjour par ailleurs en 2021 le pays dont
les ressortissants sont les plus
nombreux à acquérir la Naité française
et le Maroc avec 16 % au total devançant
l'Algérie au-delà du nombre de titres il
faut tenir compte des liens de causalité
historique il suffit de regarder nos
voisins européens en Belgique
l'immigration en provenance de la
République Démocratique du Congo est
croissante et surtout s'inscrit dans
depuis les années 90 dans la logique
d'étude puis d'installation de même le
Portugal a signé en 2022 un accord avec
les états de la communauté des pays de
langue portugaise qui permet la la
délivrance de visas temporair et de
visas permanents sans la vie des
services des étrangers et des frontières
cet accord couvre six pays notamment le
Brésil et la Guinée BO vous voyez que
s'il est original l'accord de 1968 n'est
pas une exception deuxièmement la
dénonciation de l'accord n'apparaît pas
comme une solution pertinente d'abord si
le séjour des Algériens relève du droit
dérogatoire au droit commun il laisse
toutefois au aux autorités françaises
une véritable marge de manœuvre et sur C
c'est sur cette marge de manœuvre plutôt
que sur le plan diplomatique qu'il faut
jouer le contrôle de la délivrance des
visas est en effet largement
administratif selon le rapport toujours
de Fondapol précité il y a eu en 2017 et
2020 une politique très stricte d'examin
des demandes de visa cela a permis de
réduire le nombre d'entrées avec 183000
visas délivrés en 2019 contre 411000 en
2017 la France ne subit donc pas les
dispositions de cet accord on pourrait
d'ailleurs se demander pourquoi ni
Jacques Chirac ni Nicolas Sarkozi qui
connaissait pourtant ce sujet n'ont pas
décidé de mettre fin à cet accord
bilatéral enfin permettez-moi de
rappeler que l'article 1er prévoit que
le contingent de travailleurs algériens
entrant en France sera fixé de nouveau
d'un accord commun
l'accord de 1968 prévoit donc un
dialogue particulier sur la question des
quotas troisièmement notre groupe
regrette les conséquences diplomatiques
de votre volonté de dénoncer l'accord
aujourd'hui d'abord parce que l'Algérie
est un acteur clé de la région du point
de vue de sécuritaire ce pays a un rôle
à jouer entre la Libye le Mali le Niger
et la Mauritanie sur le plan économique
l'Algérie est un producteur d'énergie et
courtisé comme tel par nos voisins et
partenaires européens s'agissant surtout
du gaz et du pétrole à bas prix pour
leur citoyen dans un contexte de guerre
en Russie ensuite il n'est pas à aodin
que l'accord de 1968 a été signé par les
ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'époque dans abdelazis boutflica qui
fut par la suite président de l'Algérie
pendant 20 ans enfin vous proposer de
créer un électrochoc diplomatique au
moment où le président de la République
tente de réchauffer les relations
franco-algériennes le rapport Stora et
la commission mixte sur la colonisation
tentent en effet de relancer le travail
de mémoire N naire autour de la
décolonisation de l'Algérie ce sujet
empoisonne nos relations depuis 60 ans
ne mettant pas en péril ce
processus une troisième voix serait de
rénover cet accord pour assurer plus
d'équité dans nos relations bilatérales
malheureusement vous préférez une
position radicale qui consiste à rampe
au moment où le dialogue pourrait
reprendre et quand vous aurez mis fin à
ce qui reste encore une coopération
historique vous critiquerez peut-être
l'Algérie de se jeter totalement dans
les bras de la Chine ou de la Russie
n'oublions pas dans notre histoire
l'apport important des Algériens à la
France que ce soit les archis les
sportifs comme le boxeur Marcel Serdan
ou encore l'autrice Albertine Sarasin
parmi tant et tant d'autres illustres ou
anonymes pour toutes ces raisons notre
groupe ne votera pas cette résolution je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame hugette
Tina pour le groupe Renaissance et pour
minutes
comment on monte
le c'est bon
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
nous sommes ici pour parler de l'accord
franco-algérien signé le 27 décembre
1968 relatif aux conditions d'entrée et
de séjour des algériens en France MRO
itaine pour situer le débat rappelons
juste un chiffre
12,5 % des immigrés sur notre territoire
national sont algérien et dès les
premiers mots de cette proposition de
résolution les auteurs affichent un
objectif simpliste je les cite arrêter
l'immigration de masse hurler avec les
loups pour quelques Miet de voix ne fait
pas mes chers collègues les républicains
honneur à la grandeur de notre nation
car oui nous avons des accords avec
l'Algérie et pas seulement celui de 1968
qui d'ailleurs a été revu et renégocié à
plusieurs reprises dès le départ une
commission bilatérale avait été créée à
cet effet alors qu'il soit aujourd'hui
mise au goût du jour et des évolutions
historiques en concertation avec
l'Algérie ne pose aucun
problème cela serait conforme à l' pris
de responsabilité des pères de la
République et qui sur mettre un terme à
cette effroyable guerre une guerre dont
malheureusement des familles des deux
continents portent encore l'estigmate
des grâces et nombreux l'ont déjà dit
prenez garde à ne pas relancer un triste
moment de l'histoire de notre pays celui
des ratonades car des embusqués
légèrement à votre droite ne guête que
cela des grâce ne leur servez donc pas
la soupe soyez plutôt les dignes
héritiers de Jacques CAC Philippe ségan
et bien d'autres de votre famille si
bien sûr vous en avez
souvenance eux n'ont jamais transjisé
sur la ligne de l'Arque
républicain et ils ont su tenir les
reennes de la France sans aucune
compromission avec l'extrême
droite cette extrême droite que vous
croyez aujourd'hui pouvoir doubler afin
de ramasser ces quelques voies qui ainsi
vous confondrait alors unilatéralement
dénoncer cet accord plutôt comme le
permettre des textes en réunissant sa
commission de suivi le renégocier ne
peut s'interpréter que comme une
agression envers un pays voisins et amis
ces pays voisins dont les liens
historiques profonds et intimes nous
unissent malgré tout quen serait-il de
la crédibilité de nos engagements de la
signature de la France si nous agissons
de la sorte je sais le désir caché de ce
qui de ce que vous suivez ou tâchez de
doubler comme je l'ai dit précédemment
ETX souhaitent tester la résistance de
laés de la représentation nationale sur
ce thème de renégociation des accords
internationaux car après
Alger il en ils en voudront
plus l'objectif caché n'était pas bien
sûr le frxit les voulez-vous vraiment
alors en conclusion si notre groupe vous
rejoint sur le fait que les disposition
de cet accord ne correspondent plus à la
situation
actuelle si notre groupe encourage
vivement le gouvernement a renégocié cet
accord conformément aux engagements du
Président de la
République nous sommes intimement
convaincu que la révision de cet accord
qui est donc nécessaire doit être
entreprise par le gouvernement français
et algérien dans le cadre d'une relation
de confiance une relation de confiance
qui est bien sûr en voie de construction
puisque notre premier ministre et ses
ministres se sont déplacé en Algérie
afin de raviver ses
relations nous considérons donc que le
vote de cette proposition de résolution
ne serait ne ferait que repousser cette
révision et le groupe Renaissance
privilégie l'action et les résultats à
la posture et au
déclaratif c'est pourquoi nous votterons
contre cette proposition de résolution
et cela afin de permettre au
gouvernement français d'engager les
négociations de révision de cet accord
avec le gouvernement algérien et cela en
confiance je vous remercie merci Madame
la député la parole est à Monsieur
kevinff pour le groupe rassemblement
national et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre en 1968 la signature de
l'accord franco-algérien qui occupe nos
débats ce matin avait pour but de
favoriser l'immigration algérienne en
France durant les 30 glorieuses c'était
une réponse au vement rapide de notre
économie pour encourager la venue d'une
main d'œuvre étrangère la France
comptait alors moins de 300000 chômeurs
55 ans plus tard la France en compte
plus de 5 millions et 40 % des
ressortissans Algériens vivants en
France sont chômeurs ou inactif c'est
trois fois plus que les Français cet
accord traité international ayant une
valeur supérieure à nos lois régit de
manière dérogatoire la circulation le
séjour et le travail des algériens en
France et prévoit des conditions entrée
beaucoup plus favorable que pour les
autres pays les Algériens peuvent
accéder plus rapidement à la délivrance
d'un titre de séjour valable 10 ans le
regroupement familial est quasiment
automatique sans que les conditions
d'intégration ne soient préalablement
vérifié aucune possibilité non plus de
retrait d'un titre de séjour même en cas
de trouble à l'ordre public il bénéficie
d'une liberté totale d'établissement
pour exercer une activité de commerçant
ou une profession indépendante rappelons
aussi que les Algériens ne paient pas
leur titre de séjour et que ce coût est
donc à la charge du contribuable
français tout cela fait des
ressortissanss Algériens la première
nationalité immigrée dans notre pays ils
sont près de 900000 à vivre en France
selon l'INC malgré ces facilités les
Algériens fournissent quand même un
compagent majeur de l'immigration
illégale en France il représentait par
exemple dans les hôpitaux publics de
Marseille en 2018 43 % de l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires de l'AME aide médicale
d'État pourtant réservé aux clandestins
al alors le temps est venu de mettre fin
à cette brèche dans notre ordre
juridique qui fait que les Algériens ne
sont pas soumis à nos loi sur
l'immigration et parce que le RN est
pour l'égalité l'égalité entre tous les
étrangers le temps est venu de mettre
fin à cet accord qui participe à
l'immigration de masse carburant de
l'insécurité et dont les Français ne
veulent plus et le ministre Darmanin
doit le dire car ce sera également le
cas la semaine prochaine quand nous
débattrons sur la nouvelle loi
immigration une large partie de la
population issue de l'immigration ne
sera pas concerné par les dispositions
de cette loi ce qui la rendra encore
moins efficace mais alors quel intérêt
avons-nous à prolonger un tel régime au
bénéfice d'un État qui de son côté use
de l'immigration comme une arme de
chantage contre la France au bénéfice
d'un état volontairement défaillant dans
la délivrance des laissés passer
consulaires pourtant nécessaire à
l'expulsion des Algériens sous
obligation de quitter le territoire vous
savez ces fameuses OQTF dont le
président Macron et le ministre Darmanin
nous ont main de fois promis de les
exécuté à 100 % alors que la France a
toujours un pit tau de réalisation de 12
% mettant parfois en jeu la vie de
français
innocent quel intérêt avons-nous alors
que cet accord n'est pas réciproque et
que les Français ne disposent d'aucune
facilité pour se rendre en Algérie nos
journalistes religieux hommes d'affaires
enseignants rencontrent même les plus
grandes difficultés pour y obtenir des
visas de long séjour nous le disons le
temps est venu de dénoncer cet accord le
gouvernement nous dit le contraire iluse
d'abord d'un premier argument politique
cela casserait la dynamique des
relations entre nos pays alors que le
président tboun pourrait accepter une
visite officielle à Paris au printemps
prochain mais soyons honnêtes la seule
dynamique qui est observée dans nos
relations c'est celle du nombre de visas
octroyés par la France et qui va
atteindre 300000 rien que pour l'année
2023 si le président tboun vient à Paris
ce sera d'ailleurs pour négocier de
nouveaux avantages mais aussi pour
gagner il faut le dire en lé litimité
politique en Algérie le gouvernement use
ensuite d'un deuxième argument contre la
dénonciation juridique cette fois mais
la France pourrait dénoncer
unilatéralement ce traité en estimant
qu'il est obsolète comme le prévoit la
convention de Vienne vous le savez
peut-être monsieur le ministre mais il
est considéré par les meilleurs juristes
y compris ceux du gouvernement que la
dénonciation de cet accord signifierait
simplement que les ressortissants
algériens soumis seraient soumis au
droit commun comme tous les autres
ressortissants étrangers dans notre pays
contre une dénonciation vous prenez donc
une renégociation mais l'accord a déjà
été renégocié à plusieurs reprises
chaque fois en maintenant les avantages
particuliers au profit des Algériens
cette voix est donc illusoire mais
beaucoup d'entre vous en sont conscient
car on a pu lire dans la presse que le
sujet faisait débat même entre les
groupes et les députés de la majorité et
même votre ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philipp le dit le maintien de
cet accord n'est plus justifié alors
chers collègues votons pour cette
résolution cela permettra de remettre à
plat nos relations avec Alger
d'instaurer un équilibre sans chantage
et dans tous les cas en 2027 Marine Le
Pen fera ce que vous n'avez jamais tous
eu le courage de faire en matière
d'immigration et notamment sur cet
accord qu'elle
dénoncera merci monsieur le
député je vous indique que sur cette
proposition de résolution je suis saisie
par le groupe la France insoumise du
Pest d'une demande de scrutin public que
j'annonce dans l'encein de la emé
nationale la parole est à Monsieur
Bastien lach pour le groupe la France
insumise N P et pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la Présidente chers
collègues un tissu de mensonge de
fantasme et de lubi voilà le texte que
vous soumettez à notre assemblée
aujourd'hui vous vous en prenez à
l'accord franco-algérien de 1968 que
vous accusez je cite de créer un droitut
l'immigration on croirait lire un tracte
d'extrême droite sur le soidisant grand
remplacement c'est immonde et
délirant vous brandissez dès la première
phrase le spectre d'une immigration de
masse mensonge rappelons les faits avec
12 % de sa population née à l'étranger
notre pays occupe une position très
moyenne parmi les pays de l'Union
européenne vous pointez encore la trop
grande place prise par l'immigration
familiale les fait encore le nombre de
titres de séjours lié à l'immigration
familiale est en baisse de 4 % sur les
20 dernières années on est très loin de
la
submersion vous décrivez l'accord
algérien comme extrêmement favorable
mensonge encore contreesens historique
même l'accord de 1968 a précisément été
signé pour encadrer l'immigration
algérienne volonté partagée alors par
les gouvernements du général de Gaulle
et du président
bouéien favorable il est par certains
aspects l'histoire commune douloureuse
de nos deux pays le
justifie mais par d'autres beaucoup
moins il est défavorable aux étudiants
et il n'exonère nullement les
ressortissants algériens des règles
d'accès au marché du travail et des
règles
d'éloignement surtout il y a un fossé
entre les dispositions théoriques et la
réalité que vivent des dizaines de
milliers de gens dans les consulats et
les préfs ure dossier impossible à
déposer en ligne rendez-vous impossible
à obtenir blocage administratif
infini dans mes permanences
parlementaires je reçois semaine après
semaine des familles franco-algériennes
déchirées elles ne parviennent même pas
à obtenir un visa de cours séjour pour
un grand-père ou une grand-mère qui veut
voir ses petits enfants durant les
vacances voilà la réalité et vous parlez
d'un droit automatique à l'immigration
c'est du délire pur et simple mais mais
vous savez sans doute tout cela au fond
comme vous savez sans doute que votre
texte est aussi inconséquent
qu'incantatoire il est inconséquent car
selon le Conseil d'État lui-même
dénoncer l'accord franco-algérien de
1968 pourrait aboutir à rétablir le
régime antérieur instauré par les
accords d'viant de 1962 la libre
circulation totale entre l'Algérie et la
France soit l'effet inverse de celui que
vous prétendez
rechercher il est incant
car même notre assemblée venait à le
voter ce vote n'a aucune valeur
d'injonction sur le président de la
République lui seul a le pouvoir de
dénoncer cet accord bilatéral et s'il le
dénon unilatéralement comme vous
l'appelez de vos vux il violerait le
droit international et discréditer la
parole de la France est-ce que cela que
vous voulez ce serait insensé et vous le
savez tout aussi bien alors pourquoi
vous obstinez nous ne le savons que trop
habité par une obsession morbide vous
rejouez à l'infini la guerre d'Algérie
vous flattez le vent mauvais de la
xénophobie et du racisme en espérant en
tirer on ne sait quel bénéfice électoral
inavoable vous tournez le dos à
l'histoire et à l'honneur de votre
famille politique celle du gaulisme pour
courir après le rassemblement national
cynisme et
démagogie vous n'êtes pas les seuls dans
cette assemblée à faire ce calcul
sordide d'autres sur les B de la
majorité présidentielle vous dispute la
palme et vont aujourd'hui voter avec
vous honte à vous honte à vous car les
conséquences de vos paroles sont graves
elles alimentent le climat anxiogène le
racisme et l'islamophobie qui étouffe
notre pays elles font le jeu de
l'extrême droite en accréditant ses
thèses et qui en paye les prix les
étrangers les binationaux ou plus
largement nos concitoyens issus de
l'immigration ceux qui subissent la
violence d'une administration qui
restreint et piétine leur droits la
violence d'une stigmatisation permanente
et d'une discrimination systémique et
désormais la violence de groupuscules
raciste qui se livre à des expéditions
punitives ces expéditions que vous ne
parvenez même plus à condamner si ce
n'est du bout des
lèvres c'est l'État qui se pense
lui-même en pensant l'immigration
écrivait le grand sociologue franco
algérien abdelmek Sayyad aujourd'hui
deux façons de penser la France et
l'immigration s'offre à nous une France
républicaine fidèle à ces principes
universalistes qui sait regarder son
passé en face et s'ouvrir à l'avenir
c'est la nôtre
une France raboug hanté par de vieilles
ranqueurs et effrayé par des Lubis
racistes celle que vous défendez avec ce
texte celle que nous refusons c'est pour
ça que nous voterons contre merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame emmanuard
pour les non inscrits pour 5
minutes
merci
monsieur madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
le rapporteur chers collègues nous
sommes sur le point d'examiner le projet
de loi sur l'immigration à la semaine
prochaine ce texte dépeessé en
commission par la majorité et la nupes
toujours prompte à rechercher
l'électorat qui lui manque ne concernera
pas l'immigration des Algériens pourquoi
parce que l'accord franco-algérien signé
le 27 décembre 1968 en tant qu'il relève
du droit international bénéficie d'une
autorité supérieure à la loi française
en clair le droit au séjour des
ressortissants algériens est entièrement
régi par l'accord franco-algérien du 27
décembre 1968 c'est fort dommage surtout
quand on sait que l'immigration Algérie
représente depuis près de 60 ans la
principale communauté immigrée en France
malgré les polémiques récurrentes les
chiffres sont élocant en 2021 selon
l'INC
887100 ressortissants algériens vivaient
sur notre sol soit 12,7 % des immigrés
vivants en France il n'est qu'à écouter
la bravade du président tboun qui
déclarait en 2020 avec une pointe de
mépris et de défi que près de 6 millions
d'Algériens vivaient en France géris
cette estimation n'en révèle pas moins
combien les autorités algériennes
comptent sur la masse de la diaspora
algérienne pour peser dans leur relation
avec Paris au-delà de ces chiffres
saisissants et malgré les révisions de
85 94 et 2001 ces accords
franco-algériens sont fondés sur des
dérogations au droits commun fixé par le
Code de l'entrée du séjour des étrangers
et du droit d'asile alors que la
diaspora algérienne les personnes nées
en France d'au moins un parent immigré
estimé à 500 63000 personnes en 2011
était réévalué à 2,6 millions de
personnes à minima en 20199 inutile
d'égrainer ici la trop longue liste de
ces dérogations qu'il suffise de
rappeler qu'il n'existe à l'inverse
aucun texte concernant l'entrée des
Français sur le territoire algérien
qu'il suffise de rappeler que par
exemple le coût administratif de
l'émission des certificats de résidence
revient intégralement au contribuabl
Fran
là où les étrangers issus d'autres pays
non européens doivent s'acquiter d'une
somme de 225 €. la question de la
suppression de ces accord et de ses
droits exorbitants se pose aujourd'hui
avec une particulière acuité non
seulement le contexte n'est plus le même
qu'en
1968 non seulement le gouvernement
algérien ne respecte toujours pas ses
propres obligations en matière de
laisser passer consulaire mais il est de
plus en plus insupportable de voir que
les visas accordés par la France sont de
devenu un droit je cite un prix à payer
par la France pour la colonisation de
l'Algérie 132 années durant comme le
déclarait déjà en mai 2012 le président
bouteflica tout se passe au fond comme
si la guerre d'Algérie n'avait jamais
pris fin non la France ne doit plus rien
aux Algériens et encore moins quand leur
gouvernement successifs ne cesse
d'humilier et d'insulter la France et
les Français dernière nouvelle en date
le gouvernement algérien demande
l'interdiction de l'enseignement du
français dans les écoles privées
algériennes ainsi que l'organisation de
session du baccalauréat français à Alger
et que dire du rétablissement en juin
dernier d'un vieux couplé antiffrance
dans son hymne national France tu devras
rendre compte ce dont se félicitit
l'ancien secrétaire général de
l'Organisation nationale des mjahidin
non la France n'a plus à être la soupape
le réceptacle
le régulateur l'exutoire des problèmes
internes qui grandrainent une Algérie
qui ne sait plus quoi faire d'une
jeunesse au chômage et qui nous envoie
chaque année toujours plus d'étudiants
qui ne ré qui ne repartiront jamais non
la France n'a plus vocation à accueillir
toujours plus d'immigrés algériens qui
viennent trop souvent pour bénéficier de
la la générosité de notre système de
santé et d'une ame dévoyée non la France
n'a plus à accueillir toujours plus de
ressortissants algéri qui sont pour 41 %
des plus de 15 ans inactifs ou chômeurs
non la France n'a plus vocation à
accueillir une délinquence algérienne
qui représentait en
2021 20 % au total des étrangers écroué
voilà pour les chiffres mais il y a plus
grave comment comprendre en effet que
selon les derniers chiffres en notre
possession qui date de 2008 seul 12 %
des enfants d'immigrés algériens étaient
diplômés de l'enseignement supérieur et
que 24 % d'entre eux n'étaient pas
diplômés au-delà du brevet comment
comprendre que de trop nombreux jeunes
Français d'origine algérienne ne se
sentent pas français ces données parlent
malheureusement d'elles-même ce ne sont
pas simplement ces accords qu'il faut
dénoncer c'est toute notre politique
d'assimilation et d'intégration qu'il
nous faut revoir je vous remerci merci
madame la
députée laion général est close la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Olivier
bech ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de
[Applaudissements]
l'étranger madame la
Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés dans notre
pays dans notre société tout entière et
depuis un certain nombre d'années pour
ne pas dire de
décennies l'immigration est un sujet qui
cristallise les tensions des débats qui
se tiennent régulièrement dans cette
assemblée jusqu'à celui qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui en sont évidemment l'une des
expressions depuis 2017 et sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République les gouvernements successifs
ont fait en sorte de prendre en la
matière des positions
équilibrées le projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration actuellement à votre étude
en est un parfait exemple il vise à nous
permettre à la fois de mieux expulser
les individus qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur notre territoire et à mieux
intégrer ceux qui ont vocation à y
rester le ministre de l'Intérieur a
d'ailleurs résumé le projet de la façon
suivante simplification intégration
fermeté mais il est un autre sujet
mesdames et messieurs les députés qui en
France attisse les passions il s'agit de
la relation forte et c'est le fruit de
notre histoire que nous entretenons avec
l'Algérie
c'est le cas d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans
notre hémicycle où l'accord de 1968 est
remise en question est montré du doigt
par certains comme la source de tous les
mots liés à l'immigration en
France ce débat m'amène aujourd'hui
devant vous au sein de cette assemblée
pour vous
répondre mesdames et messieurs les
députés qui app à dénoncer C ord vous
prétendez qu'il s'agirait là d'un moyen
de mettre fin à un droit automatique à
l'immigration et à une immigration de
masse or on ne peut décemment affirmer
que mettre fin à l'accord de 68 c'est
arrêter
l'immigration
l'équation s'il vous plaît seul monsieur
le ministre a la
parole l'équation mesdames et messieurs
mais vous n'entendez rien parce que vous
n'arrêtez pas de parler non vous
n'entendez rien parce que vous n'arrêtez
pas de parler seul monsieur le ministre
a la parole s'il vous
plaît ceux qui
présentent cette équation comme telle à
des fins idéologiques politiqu
électoraliste cherche en fait à faire
adhérer notre société à un
leur il y a dans cette équation de
nombreux facteurs à prendre en compte de
nombreux faits et de nombreux chiffres à
manier avec prudence pourquoi
essentiellement parce que cet accord ne
donne pas je vous cite un droit
automatique à
l'immigration cet accord n'est pas la
porte ouverte je cite encore une fois
vos mots à une immigration de masse
pourquoi il n'y a pas de droit il n'y a
pas de droit automatique au visa ni de
court séjour ni de long séjour pour les
Algériens c'est une
réalité dénoncer cet accord ne réglerait
donc en aucun cas la question de
l'immigration illégale à laquelle notre
pays et une grande partie des pays
européens font face C cette immigration
illégale que nous
combattons le gouvernement s'oppose donc
à la dénonciation de l'accord
franco-algérien du 27 décembre 1968 et
défend au contraire la nécessité de
l'ajuster à la fois à la réalité de
notre relation avec l'Algérie et à nos
objectifs en matière
d'immigration en premier lieu je
voudrais vous assurer que dénoncer cet
accord ne réduirait pas l'immigration
légale en provenance
d'Algérie mais souffrez quand même qu'on
vous réponde mesdames et messieurs on
vous a
écouté
dans l'hypothèse du
dénonciation les Algériens seraient
simplement soumis aux dispositions du
droit commun des étrangers si dans
certains cas le droit commun est plus
restrictif que l'accord de
1968 il peut dans d'autres cas être plus
libéral admettons que l'accord soit
dénoncé les demandes de visa déposé
seraient tout simplement examiner selon
de nouveaux critères c'est
tout aucun argument sérieux
ne permet d'affirmer que le volume des
titres de séjour diminuerait
automatiquement j'ajoute qu'il est
illusoire de penser que c'est
l'existence de cet accord qui pousse les
migrants algériens à faire le choix de
la France la dénonciation de cet accord
n'aurait donc aucune incidence sur les
migrations irrégulières
ensuite n'écartons aucun élément de
l'équation et n'oublions pas que la
dénonciation de l'accord nous exposerit
à une réaction des autorités algériennes
qui aurait de sérieuses conséquences et
pourrait conduire à geler notre dialogue
migratoire or la fin de notre dialogue
migratoire ce serait la fin de la
délivrance des laissés passer consulaire
pour les consulats
algériens en France et donc la fin de la
possibilité pour la France de faire
admettre les ressortissants algériens en
séjour
irrégulier la fin des laisser passer
consulaire cela veut dire aussi qu'il
faudrait envisager une sortie en masse
des ressortissants algériens se trouvant
dans les centres de rétention
administratif ce serait fortement
préjudiciable en particulier pour les
profils les plus
signaler nous avons donc besoin de ce
dialogue migratoire et même si nous
pouvons et nous devons toujours mieux
faire notre coopération en la matière
avec l'Algérie est en amélioration en
particulier s'agissant de la délivrance
des laisser passer
consulaire j'en viens à un autre élément
déterminant de cette équation complexe
que vous nous proposez en réalité de
résoudre si
simplement nos relations militaires et
sécuritaire avec l'Algérie pourrait être
affecté avec des conséquences directes
sur la sécurité de notre pays et des
Français notamment en matière de lutte
contre le
terrorisme les réseaux criminels et
l'immigration g ces coopérations
aujourd'hui elles fonctionnent bien et
en tant qu'élu vous savez combien elles
sont importantes pour la sécurité de nos
compatriotes
ell nous permettent d'arrêter des
personnes qui ont appartenu à des
groupes
terroristes et menacent directement
notre sécurité s PLA s'il vous plaît
seul monsieur le ministre à la
parole je je répète seul monsieur le
ministre à la parole merci si on peut
continuer si ça ne vous dérange pas trop
voilà et oui alors mais c'est pas parce
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur le fond
que vous n'avez pas à respecter le débat
démocratique c'est question sécuritaires
seul monsieur le ministre a la parole
ces questions sécuritaires mesdames et
messieurs les députés elles nous
permettent d'arrêter des personnes qui
ont appartenu à des groupes terroristes
et qui menacent directement notre
sécurité
privé de nos Cau d'échange nous
détecterions moins vite et moins bien
ces profils dangereux qui pourraent
rejoindre la France comme ministre
chargé du Commerce extérieur je
rappellerai enfin que l'Algérie est
notre deuxième partenaire commercial en
Afrique et que la France est le deuxième
partenaire commercial de l'Algérie ce
sont donc aussi indirectement mesdames
et messieurs des entreprises et des
emploi français qui serait menacé par
une dénonciation comme vous l'envisagez
de cet accord
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
le voyez cette dénonciation elle n'est
pas pertinente tant pour des raisons
juridiques que pour des raisons
politiques vous proposez de mettre fin
je vous cite à l'immigration de masse à
un droit automatique à l'immigration qui
en réalité n'existe pas dans le droit la
dénonciation de cet accord serait donc
contreproductive par rapport au
résultats que vous fixz j'en viens
maintenant à un second
point ce que nous nous proposons en
revanche c'est de travailler avec les
autorités algériennes pour ajuster
l'accord de 1968 et l'adapté à la
réalité des circulations humaines entre
la France et l'Algérie et à nos
objectifs en terme
d'immigration cet accord offre un cadre
utile au mobilités et au séjour des
ressortissants algériens en
France il est un outil qui permet la
mise en place de nouveaux modèle de
mobilité et une meilleure régulation des
migrations avec l'Algérie nous
souhaitons désormais endre vers
davantage de migration professionnelle
économique étudiante qui dynamise la
relation bilatérale et bénéficie à la
France cette adaptation mesdames et
messieurs elle est possible l'accord
n'est pas resté figé en
1968 en bonne entente avec les autorités
algérienne nous avons négocié trois
avenant de l'accord en
1985 en 1994 et en 2001 nous avons
d'ailleurs précisé de concert à chaque
avenant les dispositions de l'accord
dans un sens plus restrictif et plus
exigeant en
1985 nous avions renforcé les exigences
pour pour l'admission de ressortissants
algériens sur le territoire français en
introduisant par exemple des conditions
de ressources et précisant les
conditions de délivrance des certificats
de résidence en
1994 nous avons rendu obligatoire la
présentation d'un passeport et d'un visa
pour les Algériens souhaitant se rendre
en France et avons précisé les
conditions de péremption des certificats
de résidence en 2001 nous avons
explicité les conditions de regroupement
familial y compris pour les cas pour
lesquels il pouvait être refusé l'accord
de 1968 je le répète n'est donc pas
figé quel intérêt aurionss-nous donc à
le dénoncer alors que nous pouvons
l'améliorer quand il s'agit de réguler
les relations migratoires mesdames et
messieurs les députés ne vaut-il pas
mieux avoir un outil que l'on peut faire
évoluer que pas d'outil du tout nous
souhaitons en ce qui nous concerne que
cet
accord faire pardon faire de cet accord
de 1968 un outil au service du
rééquilibrage de l'immigration nous
voulons ainsi promouvoir les nouvelles
mobilités économiques professionnelles
étudiantes nous souhaitons également
renforcer les exigences républicaines
d'intégr
notamment en matière linguistique et
civique plutôt que de dénoncer l'accord
et d'aller ainsi droit vers une crise
politique diplomatique et migratoire
travaillons mesdames et messieurs les
députés au contraire à l'amender c'est
la voix de la responsabilité c'est celle
que nous nous engageons à suivre que
nous vous engageons à suivre en rejetant
cette proposition de résolution je vous
remercie merci monsieur mon le
ministre alors je suis saisie de
plusieurs demandes d'explication de vote
tout d'abord Monsieur Frédéric petit
pour le groupe démocrate
oui c'est je viens de vous donner la
parole monsieur petit je sais qu'avec le
Bro ambiant personne n'entend rien mais
je réitère que c'est vous qui avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
d'abord chers collègues je voudrais
remercier une fois n'est pas coutume je
trouve que ce débat a été un débat de de
d'affaires étrangères et nous avons à
part de rares exceptions nous avons été
nous n'avons pas été un café du commerce
et je vous rappelle que les démocrates
sont bien persuadés que c'est dans cet
hémicycle qu'on fait la politique
extérieure de la France même si nous
sommes pas nous chargés de l'appliquer
je voudrais rappeler clairement que nous
ne sommes pas partisans du maintien de
cet accord je l'ai dit
clairement et je voudrais faire un un
petit non je voudrais faire un petit
nombre de petites remarques la mémoire
la mémoire est un outil diplomatique
justement la mémoire est un outil
diplomatique chers collèg du Front
national effectivement il y a beaucoup
d'inactifs du rassemblement national il
y a beaucoup d'inactifs dans la
population d'Algérien en France parce
que les Algériens qui nous ont aidé
comme vous l'avez rappelé pendant les 30
glorieuses ont droit à leur retraite et
enfin les étudiants pour ma collègue
madame Ménard les étudiants qui viennent
les étudiants é qui Vinent en France
c'est une politique de la France nous
avons décidé d'aller à 500000 étudiants
étrangers en France mais chers collègues
ce que je voudrais dire est c'est la la
chose suivante la diplomatie
institutionnelle est bloquée ne
l'envenimons pas ne l'envenimons pas la
diplomatie de la société civile avec
l'Algérie est extrêmement
riche je suis moi-même député d'une
diaspora je sais ce que cela veut dire
laissons les Tisserant de ces liens
humains que sont nos diplomates
laissons-les travailler donc pas
d'idéologie pas de brusquerie un travail
patient nos diplomates sont des chefs
d'orchestre qui de plus en plus arrivent
à jouer avec toutes ces armes de la
diplomatie tous ces moyens diplomatiques
laissons-les
travailler
merci merci monsieur le député la parole
est à Monsieur Jérôme g pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
dans son ouvrage référence la France et
ses étrangers au chapitre justement
intitulé La Cible algérienne le
politologue et expert des questions de
migration Patrick veille remarque que la
communauté algérienne suscite pour des
raisons d'ordre historique et symbolique
les réactions les plus passionnelles de
la part des opposants à la présence
étrangère en France et c'est bien ça qui
se joue avec la proposition de
résolution que vous nous soumettez
car
évidemment cet accord est indissociable
de l'histoire de Laon de la colonisation
française et de la guerre d'indépendance
algérienne qui a abouti en 1962 aux
accords des Vian en dénonçant cet accord
d'une certaine manière vous manifestez
votre dénis votre surmoi s'exprime à la
fois contre la colonisation et contre la
décolonisation je vais vous le dire
parce que nous sommes tous français ici
nous avons tous quelque part en nous une
part d'Algérie qu'on s'appelle Fatia
kelwashi Jérôme Gede Michel Tabarot ou
quel que soit euh notre circonscription
d'origine vous prétendez que le statut
dérogatoire au droits commun
qu'introduit l'accord est un facteur
d'une d'une immigration incontrôlée
incontrôlable la démonstration vous a
été faite que ce n'était pas le cas vous
prétendez que l'accord euh est plus
favorable pour les euh algériens la
démonstration vous a été faite notamment
pour les étudiants que ce n'est pas le
cas et surtout cette décision remettrait
en place la libre circulation
systématique des ressortissants
algériens je ne crois pas que ce soit
l'objectif de Monsieur soti de rétablir
une libre circulation comparable à celle
qui peut exister entre le Var et les
Alpes Maritimes à moins que la libre
circulation dont il soit question ici
c'est celle des idées entre l'extrême
droite et la droite que vous incarnez à
travers cette proposition de résolution
pour toutes ces raisons évidemment nous
voterons
contre merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Sabrina S pour le
groupe écologiste
nup merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues vous étiez bien content de
chercher les Algériens quand il
s'agissait de combattre au côté de la
France vous étiez bien content de
chercher les Algériens quand il
s'agissait de reconstruire le pays vous
étiez bien content de chercher les
Algériens quand il s'agissait de
construire vos résidences secondaires et
vos piscine mais aujourd'hui alors
qu'ils sont intégrés qu'ils ont les
mêmes boulots les mêmes aspirations les
mêmes rêves alors qu'aujourd'hui il
partage le même idéal de société les
mêmes rêves que vous tous là c'est non
vous vous servez d'une niche
parlementaire pour faire la pire des
politiques celle qui pointe du doigt une
nationalité spécifique celle qui pointe
du doigt les Algériens et nous n'en
sommes malheureusement qu'au début avec
votre texte suivant empreint de la pire
démagogie agitant les fantasmes desés et
voulant légiférer à chaque actualité
alors nous nous le disons algériens
franco-algérien vous serez toujours les
bienvenus en France et nous nous
continuerons le travail de réparation et
de mémoire de la relation
franco-algérienne il est impensable et
je termine par là de voter un texte
défendu par une descendante de l'OAS et
applaudi par les héritiers des
tortionnaires de l'Algérie oui l'OAS
cette organisation d'extrême droite
défendant la présence française en
Algérie et qui a assassiné plus de 2000
français et algériens cette OAS qui a
même fait un attentat tentative
d'attentat contre de Gaulle et il faut
le dire que c'est assez savoureux de
voir les LR aujourd'hui réhabiliter
l'OAS au sein de cet hémicycle donc vous
l'aurez compris pour toutes ces raisons
notre groupe votera contre cette
résolution je vous remercie merci madame
la
députée la
parole
la parole est à Madame Soumia bourrois
pour le groupe GD merci merci madame la
Présidente
alors depuis ce matin nous parlons de
cette résolution d'ailleurs que vous
avez déposé en tout premier certainement
parce que c'est un sujet qui vous
préoccupe au plus haut point vous
dénoncez l'accord franco-algérien qui
est pour moi
irresponsable mais ne soyons pas dupe ne
soyons pas dupe ce sujet que vous avez
mis dans votre niche en première
position est
placé dans un contexte et pour cette
future loi d'immigration parce que vous
voulez toujours toujours toujours et
toujours casser l'immigré que vous voilà
vous introduisez toujours ce sujet lundi
prochain la loi immigration est votre
seul sujet il est seulement dans votre
viseur c'est clair pour vous les
immigrés sont responsables de tout ils
sont responsables du chômage de
l'inflation de l'échec scolaire et j'en
passe vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
des mensonges vous avez énuméré toute
une série de mensonges votre discours
manque d'humanité votre discours manque
de responsabilité moi j'ai plutôt envie
de croire à des liens reconstruits j'ai
plus envie de croire à des relations qui
soient apaisé
constructif avec des relations qui
soient avec des part partenariat par
exemple et on peut toujours se donner le
temps et je serai toujours là à votre
côté justement pour resserrer ces lien
nous avons besoin d'une république
solide et nous avons besoin de ce lien
entre ces deux pays qui ont un passé
commun et qui ont tant tant tant de
choses à voir ensemble ne le perdons
jamais de vue je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à
monur remlement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre bon une fois n'est
pas coutume nous avons entendu
absolument n'importe quoi venant de la
gauche et il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui
ils ont été rejoints par Renaissance et
par le gouvernement non la dénonciation
de cet accord n'implique pas le retour
aux dispositions des accords déviant de
62 et la réinstauration d'une libre
circulation totale entre la France et
l'Algérie c'est totalement faux les
meilleurs juristes le disent y compris
dans des des notes adressées au
gouvernement l'accord de 68 impliquait
une abrogation de la des accords déviant
de 62 et c'est donc le retour au droit
français commun à tous les étrangers qui
s'appliqueraient j'ai aussi entendu des
groupes se plaindre des restrictions de
certains droits au détriment des
Algériens à cause de cet accord mais
alors dénonçons cet accord et permettons
aux Algériens d'avoir les mêmes droits
et les mêmes devoirs que tous les
étrangers dans notre pays je l'ai dit
tout tout à l'heure 200000 visas
délivrés par la France aux Algériens en
2023 600000 titres de séjour accordés à
des ressortissants algériens en 2022 40
% des Algériens de plus de 15 ans qui
vivent en France sont au chômage ou
inactif les ressortissants algériens ça
a été dit représent à eux seul 20 % de
tous les étrangers incarcérés dans notre
pays soit plus nombreux que tous les
ressortissants des pays de l'Union
européenne réunis ajoutons à cela un
gouvernement algérien qui ne coopère
absolument pas dans la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine qui bloque les
laisser passer consulaires qui
intervient dans la politique intérieure
de la France lors des émeutes de juin
2023 qui utilise à nos dépend l'arme
migratoire le chantage migratoire et
pitié pitié ne mélangeons pas tout comme
vous avez tenté de le faire on ne parle
pas dans cet accord des franco-algériens
ou des Français d'origine algérienne on
parle des étrangers algériens et cet
accord il est au-dessus de toutes nos
lois sur l'immigration nous ouvrons la
semaine prochaine un débat sur une
nouvelle loi immigration qui ne
concernera pas les Algériens soyons
cohérent les Français veulent que nous
nous attaquions à l'immigration massive
cet accord en est indéiablement un des
ressorts alors
dénonçonsle merci la parole est à
Monsieur Léo Valter pour le groupe
philipes voudrais revenir sur ma
première expérience dans cet hémicycle
où le premier discours que j'ai entendu
je le rappelle était un discours
nostalgique de l'Algérie française et
niant les crimes de
l'OAS alors
plusieurs de mes collègues l'ont dit on
a tous en nous un morceau d'Algérie moi
j'ai grandi en partie là-bas je viens
d'une famille d'Algérie une famille de
pieds noir qui est resté après
l'indépendance et j'ai des souvenirs
très forts là-bas je me rappelle en
particulier de la de la Coupe du Monde
82 où l'Algérie avait battu l'Allemagne
et où ensuite tout Alger se levit et
hurlerit à chaque but de la France à
Séville je me rappelle il y a 40 ans et
4 jours j'ai traversé Paris entre ma
mère et ma sœur j'avais 11 ans derrière
un vieux monsieur algérien qui tapait
sur une casserole en chantant ce soir
couscous chez mitéran c'était une
promesse une promesse de liberté une
promesse d'égalité une promesse de
fraternité et aujourd'hui avec des
sous-entendus racistes insupportables
vous stigmatisez toute une
population alors moi je voudrais dire à
mes compatriotes d'origine algérienne à
Amien où j'ai grandi à Marseille où j'ai
vécu je voudrais dire à mes frères et
sœurs d'Algérie qui sont encore là
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas en notre nom
que ce texte est
proposé je trouve insupportable qu'on
soit encore en train de discuter de ce
genre de choses et ma collègue SBA l'a
dit on va malheureusement en parler
ensuite alors je vous le dis si ce texte
est voté ce ne sera pas en notre nom
nous voterons contre pour l'égalité pour
la fraternité et pour la liberté je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur loï
kervrand pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horison merci madame la Présidente
rapidement d'abord sur la forme je crois
que je veux redire qu'il est important
que le Parlement les représentants des
Français s'expriment sur les questions
de politique étrangère et je je veux
redire notre amitié au président et à la
commission des affaires étrangères et
singulièrement sur un sujet comme
celui-ci puisque sur ce sujet l'accord
dont nous parlons fait que le droit de
que nous votons tous ici ne s'applique
pas à un million de d'Algériens qui sont
sur notre sol et a des millions
d'Algériens qui peuvent faire souhaiter
le rejoindre et sur le fond sans redire
ce qu'a excellemment dit ma ma collègue
Stéphanie cocher tout à l'heure redire
d'abord que nous devons pas être
prisonniers de la mémoire et que la
politique mémorielle de noit pas être
l'alpha et l'oméga de la
et redire que le groupe horizon
considère que cet accord est trop
dérogatoire par rapport à tous nos
autres accords internationaux et à notre
droit et qu'en conséquence nous voterons
pour cette résolution merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Michelle
Tabarot pour les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
j'ai été mise en cause de façon
ettetinée et je voudrais
vous je voudrais vous rappeler que le
règlement interdit toute mise en cause
personnelle ce que vous n'avez pas
hésité à faire il vous interdit de
m'interpeller comme vous l'avez
fait s'appelle l'article du
rglementiteis
juste de mon histoire familiale que je
n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir de
vous vous étiez les amis du FLN qui ont
aidé à tuer des français en Algérie et
vous êtes aujourd'hui les amis du Hamas
les amis du Hamas qui tu les
Palestiniens les amis du Hamas qui ont
été d'une barbarie incroyable avec les
Israéliens donc à partir de là aucun
commentaire à entendre de
[Applaudissements]
vous je vous dirai simplement parce que
je vais revenir à ce qui nous importe
aujourd'hui que je laisse les partis de
gauche à leur délire sur la colonisation
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec ce
texte
aujourd'hui monieur deog monsieur de
Logu
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux fois ça fait deux fois vous
aller trop loin mais quoi qu'il en soit
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saisour'
aujourd'hi madame Tabaro à la parole
s'il vous
plaît madame Tabar la parole monsieur
deog vous plî madame la Présidente
j'espère que vous prévoz
V
aujourdhui enfin enfin je
comprends je comprends que ce texte pose
des problèmes aujourd'hui qu'il gêne
cette cet extrême gauche qui ne veut
rien entendre et qui surtout ne veut pas
travailler pour le bien de la
France nous nous avons la volonté de
dénoncer cet accord par nous lourd
conséquen aujourd'hui la loi sur
l'immigration ne s'appliquera pas aux
Algériens il y aura toujours des
facilités pour rentrer sur le territoire
et pour s'y installer toujours des
facilités pour le regroupement familial
vous avez beau minoré l'impact de cette
accord mais il est réel et ce n'est pas
une simple révision qui pourra le
minorer voilà pourquoi je renouvelle mon
appel à tous ceux qui partagent nos
convictions pour voter en faveur de
cette proposition de résolution et je et
je dis PL seul madame Tabaro a la parole
chacun a pu s'exprimer non chacun a pu
s'exprimer seul madame Tabaro à la
parole
merci et je
dis arrêz arrê personalit qui on Fa
chacun pu s'exprimer seule madame
tabarou a la parole voilà et enfin j'en
appelle au gouvernement qui devrait se
souvenir qu'en ayant révisé trois fois
déjà cet accord il n a eu aucune
que depuis 2017 vous essayez de tout
faire avec le gouvernement algérien le
président est allé même plusieurs fois
en faisant en battant sa coupe et en
venant avec 16 ministres pour changer
les choses et que le président tboun a
refuser les laisser passer consulair
donc voyez bien ce qui se passe et
prenez les décisions qui s'imposent
avant d'examiner le texte la semaine
prochaine sur
l'immigration merci madame la députée je
vais mettre au voix la proposition de
résolution je rappelle qu'il y a un
scrutin
public j'invite chacun à regagner sa
place le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votant 267 exprimé 265 majorité 133
pour 114 contre
151 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté je vous propose une suspension de
séance de 2
minutes